this video purports to show fighters
from the paramilitary rapid support
forces at the presidential Palace in
hartum it's the office of the head of
the army General Abdel fatah al-burhan
but the rsf says it's in control of this
government building
there's been more intense fighting in
the capital as the two sides battle for
control that's despite the announcement
of an extension of a ceasefire for one
week after mediation efforts by South
Sudan's president salvakia
looting is still a problem in battery in
the northern part of hartum Thieves have
stolen clothes and textiles from every
store at this Market the UN says the
deteriorating situation is making it
difficult to deliver Aid it's
humanitarian Chief who visited Port
Sudan says security guarantees are
needed even when there is no formal
magical ceasefire we will still require
agreements and arrangements to allow for
movement of staff and supplies we will
need to have agreements at the highest
level
and very publicly and we will need to
deliver those commitments into local
Arrangements that can be depended on the
fighting and instability is pushing more
families to flee the capital this bus of
evacuees is heading north to the Eastern
Red Sea Coast along the way they pass
through several checkpoints some are
controlled by the Army others by the
rapid support forces
people coming from khatum who are
escaping the war and trying to find
Safety and Security arrive here under
very difficult circumstances some people
who have passed through here don't have
food some are sick some are very old
in Port Sudan Navy ships commercial
ferries and airplanes are shuttling
people out of the country authorities
say around 13 000 foreign Nationals have
left in recent weeks but more evacuees
arrive each day and the city is
struggling to cope
we've had a big problem with
accommodation in the area ceilings are
currently living on the street some
families open their houses to families
but for us youths we've been staying in
the mosques and we've been getting help
with basic needs food and drink
despite the poor conditions the influx
into Port Sudan will likely go on until
the warring sides agree to a ceasefire
that holds Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
aldazarus Mohammed Altair reports from
the city of bakri in Northern Khartoum
state
is
this is one of the major markets in the
body area of Khartoum for selling
clothes in his textiles and it came
under a wave of theft and looting this
happened because of the lack of security
as you can see the shops are robbed of
whatever stocks they had
as we speak we can hear the sound of the
anti-aircraft Fire by the rapid support
forces against the Sudanese Army's
warplane which have been hovering over
this area
the fighting in Bari has been mostly
disenchelling in artillery throughout
the past three days
the Army has intensified the airstrikes
as you can see the fighter jet directly
above our heads face aircraft fire
defend it off
some shop owners have come to collect
whatever is left from their property
large numbers of these shops have been
totally emptied of their stock this is a
result of the recent crisis and the
fighting region within the capital